I'm Charles Pugh my power shower and
we'd be talking about the unity and the
integration with the Wolfram language
okay um hi well thank you for being here
I'm Charles Poole and I'm a low-power
and Jung Jae Beom and there you are
going to assist you during this whole
session of unity or hands-on on unity I
think for the next five to ten minutes
we are going to install unity link on
your computer and hopefully you most you
all have unity already if you don't we
are going to help you on that and while
we are doing that
myleik will entity knows all right so
the agenda for today
first can go over setup don't do a quick
start to see we can do with unity don't
do a more detailed overview of unity
link going through a Roble example doing
things such as creating game objects I'm
messing with properties and components
and so on then we'll do a quick talk
about assets and then some unity
primitives so now I think Charles should
be coming around with flash drives right
on the page for this hands-on you should
also find the file there so you should
ha ha do not
yes
who else
so if you click on it you get the zip
file
and after that
Oh Mike
does it matter that you need to have
detached version of the jockey we build
packet
perfect and it works so if you download
the file so if you download doing if you
download a file you unzip it you will
get a unity the right way you just write
actually the right way to operate the
right way you do and you're on padlet
will be partly data and after that you
just do a unity link to load it so
fortunately this is still on beta and so
that development so we kind of have to
manually give you the package
you can't get a raise of hands for who
has it working right now all right
so people over there who still need to
get that working
okay all right all right that is the
hardest part so once a pina mic
installed also make sure you have unity
installed can I go to the store web page
here or Rodney Genie link and then
install unity most people have unity
install as well I'm not sure you only
know it 4.2 it's fine okay all right one
side it's installed naturally start so
first you'd run into you until it with
the package let it load here they'll run
uni open this will open the unity
project selection window as you'll see
here so we're here we're going to kind
of go ahead and create a new project can
name it whatever you'd like it's where
you want to load the project I was put
on my desktop I had a create project
okay so we're gonna start with a quick
physics physics demo we're gonna have a
spiky tail fall down land on a ramp and
roll towards the camera so see now that
unity is open so we can see the
interface here on the Left you'll have
your game objects and the center you'll
have your scene on the right you'll have
your game object components of the
currently selected game object over here
and then at the bottom here you have
your asset file or folder all right so
we can start with some actual making a
spiky and I've seen does everyone see
the presentation slide yeah is what I
wanted to actually ask if you have the
presentational slide it should be in the
same zip file
okay so once you have the presentation
open if you go to this slide you can run
this first one here this is creating a
game object you give it a name and then
he have it some sort of geometry you
know giving it the ploidy trend data for
a spiky so I go ahead and run that
[Music]
yes that just that needs you in your
wing statement
[Music]
sorry Tasha under your own version try
again
all right the call needs your new ink
open unity
create a new project give a name place
create project
all right and then you should she see
the Wolfram assets folder down here and
that's how you know it works correctly
so if you go back to this slide we can
create that spiky now we see here return
a game object and added the spiky to the
scene so you can see the spiky game
object on the left over here where you
can select it you can move it around
wherever you want we can go ahead set
some properties on it so if you want to
make it a red we can set the property of
its material its color property to red
do that like over here let's see now
it's red we can also change its position
so we can go ahead and move it up and
back some so now we see it's a little
higher up here and scene view we can
create a rigidbody on it this will make
it affected by physics so it actually
fall with gravity I interact with other
objects and then we can also set a mesh
Collider to comebacks this is required
for oh yeah
did you get the presentation notebook
all right so once you have a rigidbody
we then set the mesh Collider so we get
a reference to that component using the
Unity game objects function here then go
ahead to the property of the mesh
Collider it's convex property to true is
required for any objects that move with
the collider
let that run I can see we have over here
so we have our spikey object if we only
had its components on the right side
here we can see how the mesh renderer
the mesh filter that contains a spiky
mesh we also have the mesh Collider
that's now set to come back seagulls
true we also have the rigidbody it's now
is affected by physics so we go ahead
actually run this I should see it fall
probably camera and there it goes so
make it a little more interesting we can
try and add something for it to land on
we're gonna do that by creating a plane
I'm just gonna call it platform tell me
how they came up with here we get a look
over here and we'll see it right there
the center of our scene now I want to
kind of resize it so first we'll stretch
it out I get three times as big by
changing the local scale property on
that platform ever see it's a lot bigger
and now we actually want to be a ramp so
the spiky will roll down it so we can
actually change its rotation properties
give it a slight tilt so now I can see
it's tilted toward our camera I'll check
the bigger here so our spiky up in the
air we have a platform tilted towards
the camera over here
and go ahead and run that
now we see the spiky rolled towards the
camera that's a little boring so we can
try to line it up a little bit first
let's delete that one spiky we made by
calling delete uni game object and the
spiky name and call that we'll see her
spiking that disappears then we want to
get a reference to the light in the
scene and decrease its intensity from 1
to 0.25 this will make the scene a
little dimmer look over there
now it's a little less bright
now it's also create a uni mesh for a
spiky this mesh can be reused multiple
times for different game objects so does
not the create a new one every time we
make a new game object now we had this
large loop of code that would go through
for 10 times right now it will create a
game object that's a spiky give it the
mesh we just made it'll set its position
to a ran a position at a random height
I'll set it scale to be half the size of
that original spiky and size material to
be a random color it's kind of like
going on here
so the initial call here uses the name
in the mesh and there's this option
called properties where you can set all
the properties you want for that game
object and one call instead of doing it
Y by Y like we're doing before then the
next line down here this sets a convex
property to true on the mesh Collider
which is required for anything that's
moving then we create the rigidbody
they'll have it be able to use physics
and follows gravity and then last we
will create a light will attach that
light to our spiky game object and we'll
set its color to be the same color as
it's Mikey and change its intensity and
range so go ahead and run that they
might take a second here
so we should see on the left here it
should add about ten spy keys and there
they are
so if we zoom out here it's kind of hard
to make out but you can see how the spy
keys are all different heights and all
entirely randomised positions so now if
we go ahead and run this should see
something a little more interesting I
have colored spy keys alright that was a
little fast so now let's do a little bit
of a slower overview of beauty let's go
ahead and close unity using this close
unity function then we can open up
default example called roll ball and
that's an example data now sloping that
should be in the union package thirsting
around
is anyone able to open the roll ball
example
you do not have the rollerball example
on your current package well so let's go
through it so it kind of warned about
how to use you know D alright so we can
see the example here this is just a
basic game and go ahead and hit play you
know let's see we have a ball that we
can roll and collect these little spiky
collectibles it's a very simple game
all right so first we'll talk about
scenes so the scenes are the 3d
environments where all the game objects
are contained we can find the scene
using finding a new seam this will find
the current scene weird see it found a
scene called main which is the main
scene here we can also plot all the game
objects in the scene and there a
hierarchy graph so here we get this
graph which represents this hierarchy
and unity right here which you'll see on
the left side so we can see there's a
parent-child hierarchy of all the game
objects so we can see here we have a
parent called walls underneath it has
the four different walls or South eat
them east and west we also have the
parent object collectibles and see all
of its different collectibles underneath
it and that's illustrated by this graph
right here all right so do something
simple like finding the position of a
game object first you can find a game
object using this find unique game
object function just give it the name
whatever came out which you want to find
go ahead do that we see we found a ball
we can then grab the position using this
uh the brackets and then position this
will be actually the same as a property
value ball position this is just a short
form of that make a little easier to
type alright now we found position of
one game object we can go ahead and find
it for all of them and do a quick quick
plot of them see them all over here
here we have all positions of all game
objects so you can see the lion camera
up here all the collectables and the
walls on the four edges now let's
actually get more data such as the
meshes in the scene so for example we
can find the mesh of a wall let's find
the one of the east wall which you'll
see is right here obviously it's Eric
taking more prism so if we get a
reference to that game object then call
its mesh component or property they'll
return the unity mesh and they can use
the normal function to convert the Union
mesh and to the closest Wolfram language
equivalent which in this case is a mesh
region so here you see it's a cube
it's obviously not what the mesh
actually was that's because you need to
apply the transform of the object so we
see every game object in unity has a
transform component and that's how
different objects are moved around the
scene scaled and rotated so we actually
get that transform component on that
wall is calling the transform property
then we can normalize that
transformation and to transformation
function and then we can just use
transformed region on that mesh with the
transformation function in order to
apply that function to the mesh and now
we see it's the proper rectangular prism
and we can do something similar for all
the different meshes in all scenes so
here we see the entire scene all the
mesh data within the scene firstly the
ball despy he's the walls and platform
here
alright now we can talk about components
for game objects our containers for
components as you can see over here for
example this white has the light
component on it so we can go ahead and
find the ball I didn't use this Unity
game object components function to get
all the components on a certain game
object so here we're giving it the ball
so it should fight all the components on
the ball so if you look at the ball
we're here we'll see that yes all those
components are on the ball we can also
get a steel component so let's say we
just wanna get the transform of the ball
and not all the different components so
go ahead and get the transform I can
also instead of hashing at the reference
of the ball you need to say the name of
the game object which in this case is
the ball and lastly if you want to get
all the components have certain type in
the entire scene for example you want to
grab all the lights in the scene you can
just say all instead of giving a certain
game object and then enter the type of
component you want if you don't get all
the lights in the scene which it returns
to and we see that there are these two
lights in the scene
all right talk more about properties now
so how do you find about find out about
properties so first once you have some
unity object reference so here I'll grab
the ball again I can do this properties
property that will list all the default
properties for that game object or you
in the object this is actually the same
as property lists on that game object
it's a shorthand for it and once we have
our properties we can go ahead and get
the property values by just passing in
brackets the name of the property you
want so here I want the name of the ball
I just returns a name which is ball this
is also same as property value the
function this is shorthand for it I mean
other things like the ball has the same
property which will return the scene dad
son we also have some shortcut
properties and I think it's a little
easier so instead of doing this whole
unique area logic components whenever
you want get the components on a certain
game object you can just call this
components and brackets and it will
return all the components of that game
object do something similar for mesh
some meshes not actually proper you have
a game object but the mesh filter which
is a component on a game object so when
you do this dustry shorthand for
grabbing the mesh filter component on
that ball and then grabbing the mesh
property of that component similar thing
for material the material is actually a
property of the mesh renderer so when
we've got a material - we grabbing the
mesh renderer component and then
grabbing the material on that alright
you also have properties for all the
transform properties so game objects do
not actually have the position scale and
rotation on itself those are properties
of the transform component we have a
shorthand so I can just call those on
the game object itself and I'll return
the transform our properties now last
one we have parent and children
properties so for example we can grab
one to use collectable spy keys and grab
this one here and then we can call
parent on it and I'll return the parent
collectable which is this object here
once you have a parent
we can grab all the children just to
return all the collectables and we go
ahead and graph that here to make it a
little easier to see so here we see in
red we have the parent and then orange
we have all children alright lastly we
have setting properties once you know
the unity object with the properties and
a property you want to set you can go
ahead and just do a set property give it
that object the name of the property you
want to set and then the actual property
value so here I'm when I set the name of
the ball at the player go ahead and do
that and now when I get the property
name on the ball its player can also see
that over here might be hard to see but
it's been changed to player go ahead and
change that back to ball and now it's
ball again which also changed the mesh
property for example I'll create a Union
mesh here
that's a dodecahedron I can set the mesh
property of that ball to be that
dodecahedron if you look over here and
now it's been changed you also shrink
that down a little bit so it fits a
little better now it's there
let me go ahead and delete the sphere
Collider on that ball I didn't create a
mesh Collider so now I actually collide
with this mesh itself doing it set the
mesh quire to be convex every guy make
it move
and lastly actually that's it now when
we try it
I should be working with the new physics
of the dodecahedron right here so now I
can roll around as this less round shape
all right
calafate some more changes actually
change that ball to be a spiky so we'll
create a spiky mesh set the mesh
property to be that mesh I would just
created so now we'll go back and now see
it's a spiky Ghirardelli the sphere
Collider we can recreate the mesh
Collider so now it will be the spike
ease mesh Collider go ahead and do that
set it to convex and we also want to
change the scale all right
I have our spiky here and go ahead and
run it
Oh with this try that again
alright now we can roar spikey around
the scene
all right it's so a little hard to see
because it's kind of gray so let's
change the colors we do that by changing
materials so here we'll create a blue
material I'll go ahead and set the
material property of that ball or spiky
to that new blue material so now I'll
see it should be blue actually lets you
find it disappear again
alright now it's blue then we can go
ahead and set create an orange material
it's at the platform to beat that orange
material I can see I go find the
platform size material to be orange
they're gonna go ahead and set the walls
to be green to create a green material
find all the walls and set the material
to be green so how much much different
than the original I some final touch we
can change the lighting and a camera a
little bit so we can find the light in
the scene we can change it from a
directional light to a point light right
now and see its directional then it set
its type property to be a point and now
it's a point light it's a little dim so
let's make a little brighter lets its
intensity 22.5 that's a little better I
didn't go ahead and get the camera game
object find its component camera
component that's what the background
card B black book now so now I can play
it and we had different colors a
different mesh for the ruling spiky and
a black background we can roll around
and all still works
alright so if you're wondering how the
bowl actually moves so it's a pretty
simple script on the ball controller so
it's actually a custom component that we
wrote using a c-sharp you can see it
over here on the right
it's called ball controller it has a few
public properties with that had it here
and see it's a class ball controller it
has a speed an effect prefab the
rigidbody and some audio you can see a
start function a fiction update function
that actually does the movement and on
trigger function which is for when it
actually hits uh spiky collectibles so
we'll focus on the fixed update here so
we can see that uni you can get the axes
for horizontal and vertical this will
automatically get the arrow keys and
press them up or down and left and right
and then we can set a movement vector
using those input axes let me just apply
that as a force a multiplied by our
speed variable and we actually see this
script from the Mathematica side by
finding the script asset right over here
you have the asset we just get the text
property and you can see all the text
for that script all right so wait just
two assets these are new this year it's
an asset or any of the files that are in
this assets folder down here so I'll go
ahead and create a new project let me
close is this thing project alright open
a new one
and for this you don't need the roll
ball example let's do creating a new
project project from scratch
alright you go ahead and create a new D
asset by giving it a file path here so
here's assets meshes this will just
create a folder so if you don't give it
any unity object to create an asset from
so now I can see down here add this
folder called meshes I can be the bigger
we can also create something like a mesh
so I can go ahead and create that unity
mesh and then create it as an asset give
it the file path and that meshes folder
and run it and now it returns you in the
asset that is that mesh which is in this
folder let's see it here now we can also
do stuff like create audio clips so go
ahead and create an audio clip asset
from the birds example data now it
should be here I can see the birds sound
we also create materials so I create a
materials folder then we go and do a
loop or create a bunch of materials of
random colors and add them to that
folder i see all our materials here and
if we go over let's see the materials
folder and it has all our materials in
it so funny assets we have this finding
the asset function I can find all of
them you can find all you can find them
of certain types by using uh I just
specifying the type here it's like an
argument so here we see the spiky mesh
very made you also find a specific file
location you're gonna find the audio
file at this path we can also find all
the assets in a certain directory so
here gonna go to this materials
directory and find all the assets in it
and lastly we can find a corresponding
asset to us or annuity object using the
skinny D asset function so here we have
our scene and we can find the scene
asset by using o should return c NASA
let's not say job so if I actually saved
the scene do what for Mathematica yeah
for example right now you'll create
actually do it for Mathematica so i'll
have my scene
I'll call create you've seen give it a
name I've got my scene on that now let's
see it's saved over here and then we can
find that using I get unity asset on
that scene object now it's the actual
scene asset that's in the asset folder
here just as we can find and create
stuff you can also delete stuff so I can
do like that audio file now the audio is
gone we can delete the materials and
materials folder so now I see those
materials folder is empty and we can
delete a folder and all its contents so
now we just deleted the mesh folder and
the mesh inside it alright then last we
have some primitives
you should also new so primitives you
already have some existing 3d objects at
times you might want to use those
instead of loading something from
Mathematica it can be faster and you
also don't have to store extra data on
the unity side so creating primitives
you have a create unity and a primitive
name where you have a sphere go ahead
and show that here so we can see it
added sphere we can create a custom
sphere give me a position at a radius a
name now I see you've got this bigger
sphere called my sphere and we have a
lot of types of primitives
you have cubes planes like your red
sphere quads cylinders
the cylinder here and then capsules
and the plane in quadrate similar the
main difference being that the plane
mesh has a lot more triangles where
quads - and I thought something's up or
doing questions very similar things yes
these ones here
they don't actually called the unity
primitives they call the mathematical
primitives for example this cuboid will
actually call it cuboid and Mathematica
and then move that over to UD yeah if
you actually set the Alpha of the color
when you set the material color property
then it will be transparent well thank
you and if you have any question well we
are dumb down the exhibit until tomorrow
and if you are really interested to join
the beta also stop by erisa bit and we
are going to add you to the program and
if you have any questions thank you
[Applause]